-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and, now,
we're going to get to the news.
According to the latest
poll numbers,
President Biden's
approval rating is 38%,
which is the lowest it's been
since taking office.
Well, come on, America,
what do you want him to do,
something?
[ Laughter ]
According
to a new Senate report,
former President Trump directly
asked the Justice Department,
on nine separate occasions,
to overturn the 2020 election.
Nine?!
Was he in the backseat
of the car?
[ As Trump ]
Will you overturn the election?
"No!"
Will you overturn the --
[ Laughter ]
In her new book,
former White House Press
Secretary Stephanie Grisham
writes that Ivanka Trump used
to ask her
to suppress unflattering
news stories about her.
Here's what that
would look like.
[ Clacking ]
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
former President Trump
did not want to use anesthesia
for his secret 2019 colonoscopy
because he did not want
Mike Pence
to temporarily assume power,
but joke's on him
because Mike Pence
is anesthesia.
[ As Pence ]
Mr. President, I just want
to sincerely thank you
for your leadership.
Okay, he's out.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Russian President
Vladimir Putin's 69th birthday
and I think I know
what he wished for.
Universal Studios in Orlando
has announced
that the "Shrek 4-D"
simulator show
will close next year
because, it turns out,
nobody actually wanted
to smell Shrek.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterday
that it will release
11 new holiday movies
before Christmas
and I think they're
running low on ideas.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
in a new interview,
singer Meghan Trainor said
she and her husband have
two toilets next to each other
in their bathroom
so they can spend
more time together,
in case you're wondering
why there was no
"Stars -- They're Just Like Us!"
section this week.
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.